Speaker 1: We are going to be taking a deep
dove into false beliefs, delusion, misunderstanding,
confusion and something that maybe we could
or should be calling tribal psychosis.
And that's where I want to start today.
You may have heard that there are attempts
to do what some are calling audit the election
in the state of Arizona.
Now, you might say audit the election.
Which election was there recently?
An election in Arizona that I haven't heard
of?
No.
The answer is I'm talking about the November
of 2010 election now more than six months
in the past, and there is a so-called audit
of the vote taking place.
Now, I want to be 100 percent clear with you.
This is going absolutely nowhere.
It's going it's going nowhere.
The Republican controlled state Senate in
Arizona is undertaking a hand recount, an
audit of the ballots and voting machines in
Maricopa County, which is the state's largest
county.
Biden won the county.
It was a Republican stronghold.
Biden won that county by 45000 votes.
The Senate in Arizona has taken possession
of over two million ballots and 400 election
machines and has turned them over to be audited
by companies that include one whose CEO is
a promoter of debunked election conspiracy
theories.
Understand who's doing this so-called audit.
It's not even clear that the auditors are
compliant with the law about safeguarding
ballots.
But forget about all of that for now.
Here is an interview with a guy named John
Brakey, who's an official helping to run this
audit.
And he explains that auditors have a special
light with which they can check for Bambu
on the ballots.
Now, why would you be looking for Bambu?
Are you looking to make flooring or create
bamboo rope out of the ballots?
No, they are looking for bamboo fibers because
there's lots of bamboo in Asia.
I feel like an idiot even saying this.
There's lots of bamboo in Asia.
And these auditors believe that if you have
ballots with BAMN Trece bamboo fibers on them,
they could have been fraudulently smuggled
in from Asia.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I'm sure the other day at the press
conference you were talking about bamboo.
Speaker 3: What was that about?
Well, it's that there's accusations of 40000
ballots were flown in to Arizona, into Arizona,
and it was stuffed into the box, OK?
And it came from the southeast part of the
world, Asia, OK.
And and what they're doing is to find out
if there's bamboo in the paper, that camera
right there that they take a picture of the
ballot.
If you they can really look at depth and find
out, is it a hand mark paper ballot because
it's a five camera.
You can see the folds in the ballot because
92 percent of all the ballots here should
have been folded because they came in through
an envelope.
OK, so they're doing all sorts of testing
to prove if it was or wasn't.
And that's very important because the only
way you could persuade people on changing
is having facts.
And we're on a mission for facts.
And I'm auditing Elections USA.
And what we do is not about the right or left.
Audit is an acronym.
It stands for Americans United for Democracy,
Integrity and Transparency in elections.
We've been around for 17 years.
We work all over the country for the last
five years.
I'm litigation of Florida.
I've sued in Alabama.
I negotiated in Virginia, I sued in Ohio.
And I've been in 18 states just working elections.
And I all started because of the Bernie Sanders
election in 2016 with Hillary Clinton.
I'm the guy who sued the whole state.
Speaker 1: It's genuinely difficult to know
what the most outrageous thing in the.
Video is now, as usual, the conspiracy theory
makes no sense because no one Bambu on ballots
wouldn't mean anything anyway, like bamboo
can grow in Arizona.
But also, if you wanted to try to steal the
election with so-called smuggled ballots of
or massive dumps of fake ballots, why would
you fly them in from Asia where they've got
to go through customs?
Much more expensive to ship.
You would just make the fake ballots in Arizona.
It doesn't make any there's no reason to go
to Asia for that.
And then, you know, bamboo fibers I'd be more
interested in.
Look, I think barbecue sauce stains on the
ballots might be more meaningful than bamboo,
to be perfectly frank with you.
Imagine being however old that guy is, 65,
70.
I don't know.
And being so totally unable to discern reality
from fantasy in your life, if you went to
many high schools, middle schools even, and
you presented this story to teenagers about
the bamboo fibers and all of this stuff, your
average teenager is going to question this.
And this is an adult who appears to have completely
fallen for all of it.
Is it a tribal psychosis?
Is it something else?
I don't know.
Super cameras to check for bamboo.
Just imagine what is going on here.
It's like a it's like a turducken of wrong.
It's a duck inside, a chicken inside a turkey.
Or like the the Russian matryoshka dolls.
There's just another layer.
No matter how much you keep unpacking it,
it's a joke.
And when the world sees guys like this searching
for bamboo with a special camera six months
after the election, we are a laughing stock
once again.
And the fact that this is going on makes me
question how we've even survived as a country
for hundreds of years.
And believe you me, these auditors were hired
to find fraud.
They will find something even if it's just
we found some inconclusive irregularities.
We need more ballots to review.
We need more study.
We need to keep fighting this.
They've been hired to find something.
And whether they do or they don't, it will
both become part of the conspiracy.
As many of you know, the absence of evidence
very often becomes part of the conspiracy
theory for these people.
This is not ending anytime soon.
It will do nothing.
It's going nowhere.
But I expect more interviews like this in
the future.
And in fact, we'll have more clips from this
interview on our Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman show.
And you can find me on Instagram at David
Pakman